next up is metagenomic data analysis
to unravel the microbial community
to explore the Limitless potential of
metagenomic data analysis through our
comprehensive training program that is
designed for big notes intermediates and
also advanced level practitioners so
whether you are starting your journey or
seeking to expand your expertise this
program equips you with the skills and
the knowledge to excel in this Dynamic
field
now let's get back to understand where
did the metagenomics field come up from
so in the 1800s the link between disease
and the microorganisms was established
sharing light on isolated bacteria
functions and today we understand that
the human microbiome consists of
structured communities forming biofilms
with complex interactions aiding
ecological stability and advances in
metagenomics enables the study of the
vast majority of uncultivable
microorganisms within their natural
environments
so the course covers bioinformatics
analysis of metagenomic sequencing data
which includes genomic sequencing
Technologies data data utilization
analysis tool as well as real world
applications
so since the 1900s microbiome Studies
have made significant progress and
notably through initiatives like the
human microbiome project that enabled uh
that enables metagenomic sequencing
advances allows factorization of
microbiota in various human organs
presenting opportunities as well as
challenges in identifying their roles in
organ health and disease as well
so in the program we will learn about
these different types of metagenom
sequencing techniques to different types
of data that is generated we'll majorly
focus on 16s metagenomic sequencing and
the Gen and the data generated from it
such as otu sequences that is annotated
by mapping onto a reference database
such as the ribosomal database project
RDP green genes or the silver database
and such databases contain taxonomic
information for the domains of bacteria
Archaea and Eukarya as well that is
based primarily on phylogenes for small
subunit rrnas which include 16s
prokaryotes and 18s for you get out
now based on the mapping of specific
regions Amplified from the 16s RNA Gene
in this small subunit of the bacterial
ribosome
otus can be assigned to belong to a
taxonomic class of bacteria eating a
proportionate view of the community and
each Community can then be studied by
comparing with others or between similar
communities in different conditions or
individuals and such analysis includes
an in-depth understanding of data
preparation reference databases and
analytical approaches to answer specific
questions based on solid evidence upon
importantly sequencing data that
represents only one type of microbial
omics with many more becoming
increasingly available
so there are many questions about the
role of microbiome members and the
communities that are now being answered
using Next Generation sequencing genomic
data as well as mass pick approaches for
proteomics and metabolomics indeed the
next phase of microbiome research lies
in the ability to integrate
multi-ohmings data sets that combine NGS
Mass Spec and structural data with
phenotypic information about the overall
changes in the community and their
environment
and in the program we will go through
these three different pipelines that are
just briefly touch upon the first one is
the taxonomy classification when we have
the data to pipeline that denoises and
corrects errors in amplicon sequence
data providing high resolution
error-free sequence variance as output
and next we will also learn about kind
to pipeline which analyzes and processes
microbial Community data offering
diverse outputs like taxonomic
assignments diversity Matrix and
visualizations
and behind many of these methods are
scripts that are written in popular
coding languages such as R and Python
and these are also explained in the
tutorials that you will have an access
to as a part of the program that I just
take you through briefly
it includes beginner tutorials on data
importing preparation for analysis and
also standard visualization of the
process data and more specialized
package packages with publication ready
outputs that will also be covered in
more advanced lessons in the
metagenomics coursework and the case
studies that we'll take you through
we will also learn about the basics of
functional metagenomics that explores
the genetic potential and metabolic
activities of microbial communities in a
given environment
so what kind of projects can be studied
using metagenomic sequencing or
metagenomic data
in the program we'll go through these
number of application applications that
include skin conditions food sensitivity
of the gut autoimmune disorders cancer
antibiotic resistance and also we'll try
to understand the microbiome that is
involved in drug resistance and even in
ecological studies these are just few
applications that we'll touch upon that
I just mentioned but there are more such
case studies that we'll cover in the
program
in this program we'll also learn to find
and analyze data from such repositories
as the human microbiome project which
includes a data set that is called the
American gut this the citizen science
project has a lot to offer for those
interested in basic microbial
composition of different types of
samples from healthy and mildly sick
individuals